civil war seems to be heating up in dc
congresswoman alexander ocasio-cortez
not happy with her own party
for allowing a covet-era eviction
moratorium to expire
and aoc is also threatening to blow up
the bipartisan infrastructure deal
if her far-left demands for trillions of
dollars in more spending aren't pushed
through congress
the house and house leadership had the
opportunity to vote to extend the
moratorium
and there were many and there was
frankly a handful of
conservative democrats in the house that
threatened to get on planes rather than
hold this vote and we have to
really just call a spade a spade we
cannot in good faith
blame the republican party when house
democrats have a majority
if there is not a reconciliation bill in
the house and if the senate does not
pass the reconciliation
bill we will uphold our end of the
bargain and not pass the bipartisan bill
until we get all of these investments in
so dana why is this your favorite story
well the eviction
moratorium story is one of my favorites
but let me just put back a comment on
one thing when she talks about how she
they won't hold up their end of their
bargain and they won't pass
infrastructure bill but she's playing
with a smaller hand
so the infrastructure bill is going to
pass at least the senate
and has the potential of getting
republican votes the reconciliation bill
has no chance
of any republican votes so she can talk
about the house margin but that's not
that's not what matters and she's making
senator cinema's life so much better
yeah as she sits there as a moderate
democrat saying i'm pragmatic i'm trying
to get things done in a state like
arizona that's where things like that
really matter
so for her politically on the rental
moratorium imagine for one moment
if republicans had just forgotten
to work on extending the eviction
moratorium
now she now speaker pelosi then puts out
a statement on saturday night blaming
brett kavanaugh
as if that was like let's play brett
kavanaugh first of all the only reason
it was extended for another month or two
was because brett kavanaugh said
fine you're gonna i'll do it i'll do it
this time but this is not constitutional
and congress needs to do something then
they sat on their hands
and i i would ask this does president
biden think the senate should extend it
you know not all landlords are warren
buffett right and yet there are people
who all of a sudden are going to owe all
the back rent
right but here's the kicker of all of
this remember when states could not get
unemployment money out
and it was just so frustrating and was
like wait why are we the federal
taxpayer
is offering more so we are willing to
pay all this and then the states can't
get the money to anybody and they're
having to go to food banks
and they're not able to pay their
electricity bill and the stress of all
of that through no fault
of their own is happening now within
this case the federal taxpayer gives
49.6 billion dollars to the states
and they can't figure out how to get
this money out they sat on it
in new york 2.7 billion dollars and then
the democrats turned around and said
actually the landlords are to blame
the landlords you're the ones that
should apply for this money i think this
is
absolute incompetence at the federal
level
the i think that they actually i think
nancy pelosi knows that this moratorium
needs to end but here
hear me out just one last thing if they
pass a moratorium for another four to
five months where does that put you
christmas do you think anybody's going
to want to have eviction notices going
out at christmas and then the moratorium
never ends
and then what happens so yes it's my
favorite story for lots of different
reasons
so richard i didn't even get to the
thing about sleeping on the steps of the
capitol
oh that's the worst talk about it no go
ahead no you go no i'm done i'm done i'm
done
richard do you want to talk about uh
congresswoman corey bush sleeping on the
steps of the capitol when
we have millions of job openings and
restaurants are having a hard
time getting workers back to work and
rent uh landlords are having a hard time
you know paying mortgages that they
actually owe to the bank as well
well i think there's a balanced approach
here because i think dana points out a
good point in the american rescue plan
there's about 50 billion dollars of
money that is set aside to deal with the
fact that there are
both landlords who are behind in their
mortgages because there's
renters that can't find jobs or renters
who can't work for various reasons
because
kids are in school so have you and so
this money should be used more
effectively and states need to figure
out who these folks are and get to them
we know
the census bureau seems able to find
these people because according to the
census bureau there are about 3.6
million folks that will be
impacted when this moratorium goes away
so this is about government working for
the people uh and i think the government
needs to do a better job both state
federal and local government working for
people and i appreciate
corey bush for sleeping on the steps of
the capitol just because
we are having a conversation about this
issue and now we're saying
well wait a minute where did the 50
billion dollars go and how can the 50
billion dollars get to
get to the get to the right people which
is what the white house is trying to say
where is this money and why hasn't it
got to the people when we've already
allocated it
congress has passed it so how are we not
getting this money to landlords and
renters
so they could begin to pay this money so
they can stay in their homes and not be
a victim because
jesse why weren't democrats having this
conversation
in june when it was clear that it needed
to be passed through congress and that's
because they were focused on january 6
katie that's why aoc says i need to pay
for someone else's rent
because the pandemic's still a threat no
i don't and no it's not
we helped a lot of american people with
what free money
free rent for nearly a year when they
needed it well they don't need it
anymore and now they can help themselves
what did joe biden say this was the a
workers job market
go work last yesterday they were
62 coveted deaths okay
102 covet deaths i mean 102 people died
in car accidents
okay so we've neutralized the threat
from covid
with vaccines and we know that aoc wants
this free rent for life it was in the
green new deal right she even wrote it
so
she's actually on the committee that
oversees housing
she didn't see this coming she could
have written a bill
and then tried to get support for it but
instead she waited for the last minute
and then blamed the biden white house
for it yep she knows
aoc is the least effective member of
commerce
congress basically she has never written
a bill that's gotten out of committee
in her entire career she's just not an
effective legislator she'd be much
better
on cable you still like her jesse you
talk about her quite a bit
cover stupid things she does i mean if
she's still going to finish
talking about what people do that's
stupid richard that's my
job hey greg this is a broader movement
about canceling rent right
the far left of the democratic party has
had this movement going on for a long
time
universal income government paying for
everything and private business owners
being on the hook this is the uh
this is the reason why you can't even
compromise with temporary solutions
because even if you give a temporary
solution to a lefty
they're gonna make it permanent there's
no such thing as temporary whether it
was
mail-in ballots you know or it's the
moratorium
you give them and they go oh yeah sure
and we'll get back to normal no they
won't
moratorium they don't even know what
that means um and
we don't actually we i have to say we
don't talk about her at
all we talk about the stories and we're
always very
very respectful i think she's incredibly
talented
but she hasn't lived enough to be that
arrogant in her wisdom
and that is an issue with with the
problem with the democratic party
is that their hard loony left
are young and ignorant in terms of
wisdom they don't know how the world
works
you need and they're not going to listen
to me then i've said this before the
five we've raised the flags we've called
out violence canceled culture
the mob mentality but we do it it
doesn't land with the democrats
so it you need the remaining sensible
i.e older democrats to take
responsibility
you know and pretend you didn't hear it
from us you know
make it your idea and we'll salute you
but we need
we need it's time for old people in the
democratic party to take their
party back from the young and loony the
boomers yeah
come on boomers they're wisdom
challenged all right hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else